camus
claire
c
un peu de chaleur et de répit sur le
chemin de l'itinérance
le temps de se poser de manger ou de
dormir je garde quand elles sont pas
plaints je me donne à fond dans la masse
et jusqu'à 30 of trouble à 5,6 beaucoup
beaucoup d'eau des mains tendues au sein
d'une église désacralisée devenue
pandémie de kobe de 19 oblige un refuge
d'urgence temporaire
la halte du coin mise en place par trois
organismes y aurait pas de vue où on les
accueille de façon inconditionnelle tels
qu'ils sont à la porte dans un état qui
peuvent être ajoutés qui peuvent être
vraiment en état de crise on va les
recevoir les bras ouverts on va les
accompagner
il y avait une itinérance cacher aussi
sur la rive sud
on parle de personnes qui se devront se
déplacer de maisons maisons en
caoutchouc films qui vont vivre dans des
tentes l'été qui vont se réfugier dans
différents endroits et pendant la
pandémie
il n'avait plus accès à tous ces
endroits là on s'est dit mais maintenant
que tout est fermé on va s'assurer qu'à
une ressources adéquates pour pouvoir
les recevoir
on estime que la population à 79 ans a
presque doublé depuis le début la
pandémie donc on est passé de 3000
personnes assignées de personnes
l'itinérance c'était tendu un peu
partout dans la métropole et même à
l'extérieur de l'île de montréal
étant donné que moins d'activités au
centre-ville donc moins de possibilité
de demander de l'argent d'avoir des
contacts
les gens préfèrent rester dans leur
territoire où ils sont habituellement
l'autre élément aussi c'est que avant
les gens venaient chercher des services
ici mais la ccrd cela souvent sont
complets des bords ou sont fermés
carrément l'organisme souligne que la
pandémie a aggravé la situation de
nombreuses personnes déjà vulnérables
chez les femmes et chez la population
autochtone par exemple en plus de
révéler des inégalités existantes et des
chiffres par rapport aux travailleurs
pauvres
il ya 12 % +2 12% des travailleurs qui
ont des emplois statut précaire qui ont
perdu leur emploi pendant la pandémie
soit à plusieurs périodes pendant le
confinement ou qui ont carrément perdu
leur emploi comportement à 1% pour les
personnes qu'on laisse à la plus élevée
centraide a débloqué 4 fonds d'urgence
en ces temps de crise sanitaire pour
appuyer des centaines d'organismes
communautaires
le principal des filles qui est le nerf
de la guerre c'est le financement on a
eu beaucoup beaucoup de financement
pendant la période de coved les fonds au
niveau du fédéral du provincial du
municipal mais nous on ne demande pas
juste les fonds pour la cause lui
demande des fonds pour venir en aide à
ces personnes non sur plusieurs années
son organisation voudrait acheter un
terrain pour y bâtir selon lui un refuge
idéal un lieu serein quand rantissi à
l'église c'est serein c'est apaisant
[Musique]
le
ici c'est tours qui paraît je pense pas
qu'il ya des gens qui luttent apple
était dans demain avec des personnes je
consommais com - sujet que je vraiment
j'étais presque un dieu de lévis mais on
me fait comprendre je pointe de jeu
humains en détresse
[Musique]